there's been actually a rising crime
over the last
five years but really the last 18 months
and so
it's an opportunity for the president to
speak to what he's going to do to help
address that and as we've seen around
the country it is
a concern of many americans republicans
but also democrats too not necessarily
through a partisan lens
we are seeing a downward trajectory
where other cities are continuing
to see a climb now i'm the first to tell
you
that's cold comfort to a single person
who's been shot
a single person who's been killed
politicians won't blame families for
raising their kids the gangs are raising
their kids right now we have
over 17 or 117 000 gang members
that's your problem that is your
absolute problem
well crime uh waves through some big
cities across the country and it's very
tangible you can see the
stats and take a look at them chicago
up 5 18 shootings and chicago obviously
had huge numbers to begin with los
angeles new york look at portland
up 533 percent in homicides 126 percent
in shooting incidents in portland oregon
as
we get word that the president is going
to speak about crime across the country
later this week so let's bring in our
panel we'll expand it tonight fox news
senior political analyst britt hume ben
dominic publisher of the federalist
mara liason national political
correspondent of national public radio
and trey gowdy former congressman from
south carolina
brit it's a big issue always whenever
a law order becomes an issue politically
but the fact that president biden is
going to address this directly obviously
it's raised to a different level
it does uh brad and it and he would he's
wise to try to
at least say something about it what he
will actually do or propose doing about
it remains to be seen obviously but
this has always been a potent issue
politically and as you look around the
country i mean the statistics you show
just now speak for themselves but you
got to you know you got stores closing
in san francisco because they can't do
anything about the shoplifting you've
got the riot squad quit
quitting in in portland you've got those
awful scenes of violence in the streets
of new york
uh people notice this stuff and they
don't like it
and they never have so if this is still
the situation or something like it when
these midterms roll around
the gravity that the party with the
white house always faces in the first
president's first midterm is likely to
be very heavy indeed
and you know we'll the president needs
to do something
you know mara we've pointed out before
as a candidate joe biden was not for
defund the police but the democratic
party at least a wing of it
did talk about it a lot and still talks
about it about repurposing
dollars um so that becomes the issue
it becomes an issue and it certainly is
featured in a lot of these democratic
autopsies about why they didn't do
better down ballot in 2020 and a lot of
them have said the defund police
slogan became something that republicans
used to kind of tar a very wide swath of
the democratic party even candidates
that
weren't for defunding the police but i
think joe biden has a long memory and he
knows
what the issue of crime has done to
democratic
politicians in the past and it sounds
like he's going to try to get out ahead
of that
two things are true one there is a spike
in crime for a variety
of reasons but two this is an issue that
the republican party thinks
is really a good thing for them
politically of course the spike in crime
is bad for everybody
but they're pushing this and it's going
to be interesting to see
what the president says later this week
when he talks about this
and how he can help his party get
removed from that
label of of wanting to defund the police
it was uh three years ago today we lost
our
colleague dr charles krauthammer and we
often on this show
go back and look at things that he said
over the time on the panel
that seem to fit now and we found one
today
there is a reason that these murder
rates are going up
that is because we're having a
slow-motion police strike
where police are either not going into
the neighborhoods
or pulling away in a dangerous incident
or a confrontation
because it used to be if you were in a
police officer in a confrontation you're
instant
one thought would be how do i escape
alive how do i protect the people
and now he has to think how is this
going to look on the video how will i be
treated tonight in the evening news
and how will i be ultimately treated by
the
legal system and once you have to add
that factor
the policeman is defenseless
now we miss his voice every day but trey
he's hitting a note that's
you know cogent today
yeah brett i mean dr krauthammer is
right again and then you add to that the
calls to defund the police and then
the the thought wing of the democrat
party if that's the right phraseology
some of them even said they wanted to
eliminate the police and hire social
workers you have these
so-called progressive prosecutors who've
never met anyone that they think ought
to be in jail
and then you've got both political
parties both of them
have minimized acts of violence on their
side and you add to that a media that
can't tell the difference between an
arsonist and a peaceful protester
it is the most natural and probable
consequence in the world that you're
going to speak
see a spike in crime when you have seen
a spike in lawlessness
ben
well dr krauthammer's words are
obviously still true today but
i think that one of the big things that
we have to appreciate about this moment
is that smart democrats are looking
at the poll numbers that they're seeing
among
hispanic voters across the country and
they're seeing a real backlash
against not just the defund the police
rhetoric but also the rhetoric
of black lives matter the rhetoric of
anti-racism
etc things that are not viewed within
the hispanic community
as appealing to their interests
particularly when it comes to
education i mean we've seen across the
country this backlash against
teachers unions that i think
conservatives will be very wise to seize
upon
in these in these midterms to really
push back against the dominant
political power of teachers unions and
their ownership
of so many democratic politicians this
is something that i think is a
huge opportunity for republicans whether
they are able to actually
you know seize upon it whether they're
able to build upon it
is really going to be up to them and i
think that that really is an open
question going into these midterms
but it is going to be based on all of
these issues of crime
education and this type of racial
politics that i think has become so
toxic in recent years you know you're
speaking about polls
yeah go ahead one more just one more
thing brett
let's not forget the lawlessness we're
seeing along the border
uh which we are covering very well i'm
not sure how much other media is but i
think it's penetrated the public the
president's ratings on
immigration are very poor um so even if
he
begins to get some kind of a handle on
this urban lawlessness
this situation down at the border i
think is politically toxic
um you know and we hear now from the
from the white house or from reporting
from the white house that
that they're about to stop deporting uh
people who come here
illegally even as kamala harris is
telling them not to come
speaking of polls one of the pieces of
legislation that will come
forward this week up in the senate is
this voting
rights bill and in a mammoth poll the
latest mammoth poll
do you support or oppose requiring
voters
to show a photo id in order to vote 80
percent
support a voter id mara it seems like
this issue
this issue alone is pretty much closed
yes voter id has bipartisan support
that's why when joe manchin floated his
alternative to hr one it was kind of
very stripped down and just had a couple
key features
15 days of early voting voter id
national holiday for election day
democrats pretty much embraced it so
voter id is i agree
a closed case but there are a lot of
other things that democrats feel very
strongly about
like partisan control of vote counting
which are embedded in some of these new
state laws
uh around the country so yes on that
voter id maybe you could start building
some kind of compromise at least
inside the democratic party you'll never
get 10 republicans for any kind of
voting rights law
but on that one there is a consensus but
you know trey
there was a lot of talk about jim crow
relived in some of these bills and
the voter id was a big problem for some
progressives
it doesn't seem like it's a problem for
americans if you trust this poll
yeah brett that was a long long time ago
like maybe
seven to ten days ago when when
not only were they opposing voter id i
mean they've been to the supreme court
to oppose voter id
and so i always ask the the rhetorical
question i mean what is your
issue with proving that you are who you
are the problem with that poll brett is
all
18 percent that are opposed to voter id
are on the democrat side of the house
and the senate that's the problem with
the polling
they're not going to support all right i
want to turn really quickly to the
economy and we're looking at inflation
in may year over year all items up 5
you see the breakdown food energy used
cars
people are feeling it ben does this in
this moment have an effect on the
negotiations up on capitol hill with
infrastructure and these big-ticket
items
i feel like the politicians are not
paying attention to this and it is the
simmering uh sort of boil underneath
all of it i mean americans are very
aware of these increases
when it comes to canned goods when it
comes to gas when it comes to all these
different things
that you need to buy in order to live
your average american is very aware
of these cost fluctuations and the fact
that their grocery bill is turning out
to be a lot higher than it used to be
unfortunately i think capitol hill is
not paying much attention to this
and it's another reason why i think that
republicans
mindful of the midterms need to be
stressing this as a
negative outcome of what has been uh the
approach of the
biden administration to this point
pretty quickly it's it's not only the
inflation but also workers and trying to
get them to work american airlines
cancelling some 300 flights over the
weekend
i mean it's it's absolutely important
brett final word well it's
inflation is almost as toxic as crime
and if people feel that the gains that
they're making from an economy that now
seems on the verge of really booming
or being eaten up by inflation um that
is politically very dangerous indeed
all right